how are you tell me how you're doing
well I got in the chair is the benchmark
for how it go is a big thing when you're
big can I get that chair
[Laughter]
either way though if you fell down will
we be here to go viral
you'll be go viral yeah I'd be going
like this they'd bounce me up and I'd be
the gift that kept giving yeah yeah I'm
good I just got that from Chicago and
had some shows that the Improv had a
blast oh good you enjoyed it I'm signed
up still yeah good for you're so great
at it I ain't a natural and people bring
you gifts which is nice yeah you know
you're fat when they bring you a book
like eat to live people give you the
book people give you presents like that
people game it they care about me that's
a caring thing on their part II to live
then how to not die and how to not die
cookbook if you survive the first book
then you can cook and say a lot I mean
those are the kind of things you know
when you're a fat person people you know
they they'll I'm on a food plan now
where they deliver the food every week
oh I've heard about that that's good
every week's Monday
you're eating ahead of the plan yeah
yeah you can't give a fat you can't it
be like giving a drug addict your drugs
to hold ya hold these but don't use them
yeah
here's your food just eat it once a day
okay so you're way ahead now yeah I'm on
Monday but you know it just is you know
I know and people also other people who
are fat out there you know who you are
people will take you on as a project
they'll go Louie I'm gonna get you
healthy I'm gonna turn you around I go
well you better bring another person now
it's on me growing up
tell me about was your mom I mean did
you interested in foods it was it was it
because a lot of people linked it to
their mom was your mom again hook my mom
she fed it you know we had 11 children
where's 11 11th in your family yes I was
10th yeah I just slid out I didn't for
she was
[Applause]
but yeah she you know she is food to
comfort us and give us you know love I
think a lot of times when you're poor
you know like yeah you guys you guys
really didn't have much girl we did not
I mean I but you know we had to decide
whether we're gonna shut off the gas or
the lights because we could only pay one
of them mm-hmm but we always shut off
the the lights cuz my mom had a thousand
candles right I don't know where she got
him but I even said a menorah down on
the table I don't think that's right
mother yeah religious yeah but I watch
game my mom couldn't get her a birthday
gift you know I love my mom and so I
wrote her the coupon book did you ever
do that I'll wash the dishes I'll do the
laundry
I'll kill dad for you the true story
did you really you really gave her a
coupon that said I'll feel bad for you
cuz you know my dad was kind of uh you
know my dad was a great guy in all our
he was a famous musician really with
Hoagy Carmichael oh he played oh yeah
but long before I was born you know and
he was a great and he would he like to
drink and so he would always sing to my
mom when things he was that kind of it
was a very grumpy how many I had grumpy
dad yeah you know I never won one
argument with my dad no as soon as I got
close you guys that right Louie you
think you know what you're talking about
yeah I do I know I'm talking about yeah
yeah yeah I'm right about this well have
you ever been pinned down by a sniper in
France
I'm never when did your dad ever find
out your dad I hope didn't find out that
you were I promised your mom dad good he
found out he well my mom said Louie
that's an inappropriate coupon I go what
the dishes one you wouldn't really kill
your father would ja I do it for you MA
there's no expiration date on that
cookie yeah yeah one day came home my
brother Tommy was eating ice cream and I
go oh this is not good cuz we don't eat
the ice cream during the day and I
opened the door and I hear my dad there
he is
hit man Louie he called you hit man I
love that yeah you're gonna kill me
Louie Here I am and he charged me for a
whole year you know we'd go out and my
dad was kind you know he would always
introduce all the kids in the family all
11 all 11 as my son Canton my daughter
Rhea my son Roger and my daughter Mary
my son Jimmy my daughter Shanna my son
Tommy my daughter Lisa that's my
daughter Sheila hey there's hit man
Louie Louie you got your coupon book
will ya watch I'm living on borrowed
time yeah